this year Jeremy marks the 50th
anniversary of Earth Day and that's a
long time to be around 20 years longer
to be precise than the life of Holly
Maddox who was beaten and murdered at
the age of 30 by one of earth days
leaders IRA Einhorn yes the media
portray a bright picture of Earth Day
happy hippies celebrating nature but
there's a darker side to this
pantheistic bacchanal that the tree
huggers don't want you to know about
namely that the co-founder was a lunatic
killer who took his environmentalism so
seriously that he composted his
girlfriend's body in a trunk
Einhorn spoke at the first Earth Day
celebration in Philadelphia on April
22nd 1977 years later his girlfriend
dumped him at which point he flew into a
rage and murdered her but like so many
leftists before and since
Einhorn wasn't held responsible for his
crime at least not at first
in fact one year after the murder I kid
you not Harvard gave Einhorn a job
lecturing at the Harvard University
Institute of Politics the Harvard
administration welcomed the hippie with
open arms gushing in the student
newspaper that Einhorn offered a
perspective different from anybody
else's you can say that again and that
he would contribute to the richness of
our program Einhorn was finally caught
the following year when a strange red
brown liquid began to leak from the
ceiling beneath his apartment at which
point the environmental activists jumped
bail and fled the country for 17 years
before being extradited back to the
states in the late 1990s since then the
environmental movement and its
sycophants in the mainstream media have
done everything they can to distance
themselves from Einhorn the other
founders have disavowed him Time
magazine ran a spread calling the story
fake news but the historical accounts
remain and even Big Green can't deny the
photos of Einhorn on stage addressing
the crowds at the first Earth Day event
in Philly 50 years ago today happy Earth
Day everybody so the the water is
cleaner the sky is clearer but don't go
upstairs for the love of God